so here's a bit from Alexander this
whole time it was here you called your
man in for nothing
fights out there it's just me in here
did you hear what I just said I know who
you are
hey everybody we're gonna settle your
[ __ ] officer friendly this is gonna be
my episode 3 video
I think they intended for the Morales
storyline with Rick to be the big thing
for the episode but really Morgan and
Jesus wound up being the most compelling
storyline and then you had all the
Gregory stuff at the end of the episode
which I probably like the best just
because of the Monty Python level comedy
Felicity top 10 WTF and comic book
Easter eggs there's a new round of the
walking dead giveaway and I'm gonna make
some changes to the way I do Walking
Dead videos that I'll explain at the end
of the video but we start with number 10
Ezekiel and the kingdom doing that thing
where they jump backwards and forwards
in time where Ezekiel slowly going a
little bit nuts through the course of
the episode not one person we're not
gonna lose one person so you immediately
know the moment he says that at the
beginning of the episode they're
definitely gonna lose some people by the
end but they really stretch that
storyline out and because of the
admission in last week's episode fake it
till you make it baby I think they just
want to show you how this is all
affecting Ezekiel like he's very good at
being a peacetime king but they're at
war like a pro long gated war
so everybody is slowly losing their [ __ ]
but number nine couple great lines from
Morales we're gonna settle your [ __ ]
peaches this is more of that dark rigged
storyline what would Rick look like if
he had lost everything that Morales had
lost like Morales is supposed to be the
evil version of Rick because he lost his
family
whereas Rick only lost a few people but
they really want you to start hating
Morales as quickly as possible because
he sounds like a true believer Savior
like I was sleeping myself to death in a
trailer when they found me you're the
Rick that they've been talking about
this whole time we learned their names
for Maggie or the widow and they call
Ezekiel the king I love the Maggie one
two especially when they bring it back
around to Glenn when he tries to explain
all those season 1 characters that
Morales used to know who have since died
number 8
is the goodbye Eric seen so I was never
particularly attached to the character
it was wonderfully performed the actor
playing Aaron just totally sold that
especially when you see Eric walking to
meet the herd at the end of the episode
like oh yeah he's definitely dead so
baby Gracie probably going to make it to
hilltop just fine but number 7 Jesus
gets super biblical they lead the people
out of Egypt make all the Bible jokes
that you want about Jesus leading his
people out of Egypt but his awesome is
all that was this is really Morgan's
storyline like watching him slowly crack
and they even put Jared right next to
him in all those scenes like he's still
being a dick every chance he gets
anybody that gets within earshot of him
so Morgan is just the absolute worst
person to try and do that too because he
already wants to kill them all but the
thing about this is it's really just
another version of the storyline with
Tara from last week's episode where she
was butting heads with him because she
wanted to kill them all they follow it
up with that a little bit too but it's
the same storyline it's the same basic
conflict like we need to kill the
Savior's we don't want to keep prisoners
they're terrible people but we jump back
to Morales number 6 he explains what
happened to him we never made it to
Birmingham Ric I think pretty much
everybody assumed that the moment we
found out that he was a savior like up
something pretty dark probably happened
to him we get a shout out for Laurie
Shane
Andrea Glen all the people they lost but
these were people that Morales knew so I
think Ric was trying to connect with him
like remember those people from way back
in season 1 they're all dead now that
proceeds to tell him what negan did at
the beginning of season 7 where he
killed Glenn in front of pregnant Maggie
and you start to see the light bulb go
on in Morales head like he's putting the
dots together wait a minute the widow
that we keep talking about that's Maggie
Morales even does the I'm negan light
yeah I'm negan Rick like yeah he is
fully drunk the Savior's kool-aid so
number 5 I think that was mostly so that
you don't demonize Daryl too much for
killing Morales although I think most
people were upset by this because they
brought him back and it seemed like such
a big twist like oh you can't kill him
right away after you bring him back
after being gone for this long nope they
totally did it they totally killed him
one episode later that turns into more
of a Daryl Morgan type storyline where
like Daryl and
again are slowly getting darker and
darker like he had this whole idea of
Rick with the flash-forwards like my
mercy prevails over my rap so you know
exactly what Rick's Arc is going to be
this season but it sounds like the
biggest conflict isn't going to be with
the Savior's the biggest conflict is
going to be within the group with people
like Daryl and Morgan who have just had
enough of the [ __ ] like we can't trust
the Savior's just just kill them all
let's get rid of them if anybody just
goes completely off the rails I think
it'll be Morgan I don't think they want
to demonize Daryl too much but number
four the Rolling Walker attack this was
so funny
so all the Savior's are still tied up
Morgan really wants to kill them and now
it's almost like the perfect excuse
because they're still bound together but
let me know in the comments if you did
laugh a little bit when you saw them
just rolling down into the Savior's
because you hate those characters like
you really want Jared to die and now
it's almost seems like the perfect
opportunity to kill them off in some
moment of comedy but number three Jesus
versus Morgan this was a great fight
because Jesus is an amazing fighter
Morgan is an amazing fighter and you
don't know how crazy he's got he's still
in Terminator mode but he backs off it
just a little bit Jesus is like are we
done you're gonna keep going so I have a
couple criticisms for the storyline but
the performances were amazing The
Walking Dead has amazing actors that are
capable of delivering just amazing
scenes it's just that sometimes the plot
gets really redundant and they really
stretch stuff out so we've essentially
been getting the same storyline recycled
from Tara's character from last week's
episode through Morgan's character it's
the exact same argument mercy we have to
kill them no we can't kill them just
over and over and over so I think you're
just wearing on people's patience a
little bit usually the complaint about
the Walking Dead is that they turn one
hour of story into like four episodes of
content but probably my number one
moment from the episode was actually
that comedic Gregory Monty Python scene
from the end I was really hoping they
would go for it and when the gate opened
I was like oh no they're not gonna do it
but then sure enough you know Maggie
sticks her head through and starts
harassing him a little bit like what the
hell are you doing here who's Gabriel I
have no idea who that is like he
pretends not to know the person he just
stole the car from then they have the
funny moment with the pain
remember that time you ate that little
girl's pancakes what are you talking
about I did not eat those girls pancakes
and he just begs and begs and begs until
Maggie lets him and then turns around
immediately in this comedic reversal
when they roll up with the Savior's we
can't let them in they're terrible after
all the things they've done so I'm
actually really happy with what they're
doing with the Gregory character because
you know he's going to die like it's
just a ticking clock on his life in some
funny WTF moment but they've gotten to
the point where they made him such an
insufferable character that it's become
comedic so they're leaning into the
comedy of that situation but just to
clarify that twist at the end with Rick
Daryl in the shooter so he's like tell
me where those guns go and he says oh
they went to Gavin's compound he's
talking about these giant automatic
rifles those are the guns that were used
to shoot down Ezekiel's men so that was
why they cut the episode that way like
where you learn where the guns went then
you actually see the guns open fire on
everyone but obviously Daryl breaking
Rick's word and killing him on the spot
is just highlighting more of the Daryl
versus Rick's storyline it's just
another version of the Morgan storyline
with Jesus like how dark is Daryl going
to get before he comes around to Rick's
mercy storyline well let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the episode and what do you think
of The Walking Dead so far this season I
think most of the complaints are
justified I mean it's getting to the
point where we're in Season eight so
people like how much longer can this go
there was a funny headline the other day
where it was like Walking Dead
threatening us with 50 more years of The
Walking Dead so I think we've gone to
the place where the interest level has
dropped to the point where people like
to check in with the Walking Dead every
once in a while but week to week people
are starting to lose enough interest so
what I'll probably do is I'll just wait
to do my next Walking Dead video till
the mid-season finale because usually
that mean that's kind of what they do
now is it like stretch stuff out then
they'll do the really big moments during
the finales and the premieres so we'll
try that for the rest of the year then
if that ends up working out then we'll
try that for the rest of the back half
of the season and it'll be Walking Dead
videos for every couple of episodes for
like the really big moments and then we
could talk about the whole season after
it's all done but there's a new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the last winner Mike
meseta
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for all my Walking Dead videos and you
can click here for all my Thor Ragnarok
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight